my name is Catherine Piper and i'd like
to welcome you to the 2010 english 116
restaurant panel at Yale University for
the fast past few months our class has
been reading and writing different works
revolving around food perhaps our
biggest contribution as a class has been
collectively keeping an online blog on
which we posted a foodie's map to New
Haven reviews of all the food carts in
the local area thoughts on readings
recipes and array of other food related
topics to conclude this semester we
thought it would be interesting to hear
about the restaurant business from New
Haven restaurant owners Donecker and of
zinc Boone lie of Mia sushi and Jason
Silva since gave kassius Matt Walker
walls would be our moderator today to
begin could you each tell us a little
bit about two restaurants um well I'm
zinc Donna Karan and we opened in 1999
so we've been around for will be
celebrating our 11th anniversary the
September just really terrific Court
love being in New Haven when we first
started our restaurant we had the idea
of changing the menu seasonal
ingredients the first couple of months
the word on the street was we couldn't
make up our mind seasonal the notion of
seasonal ingredients hadn't hit quite
hit New Haven yet but we are pretty
firmly established now my business
partner is a chef Denise appel if any of
you have eaten there tasted her
wonderful food
what else used here that's good Frankie
uh my name also is Donna current a sink
I'll kidding aside my name is bond line
I'm from me as New Haven we're pretty
old restaurant we've been around since
the 82 I work with my mother so about 55
years old and I still you yelled and
yelled that deal with on my mom but it's
actually a wonderful experience because
we've worked together to evolve this
thing that originally was a traditional
Japanese restaurant and which now I
consider to be my vision of what the
future of sushi is going to look like
when food is stuff is made in a way
that's sustainable and when businesses
are run in a way that's sustainable so
yeah it's a constantly evolving project
where I use sushi as a medium to express
and explore different ideas about what
it is to be human
my name is Jason citizen ski I've got
caseous for mon cheri bistro we been
open for about two and a half years and
we're a cheese restaurant but we also
like to be as sustainable as possible
and a seasonal as possible took my cues
from these guys and it just be as low
key and chill as possible as well sorry
awesome so start off with we're gonna
get a little background information
about you guys so I'm going back down
the line from dawn onwards why did you
start your restaurant like what was the
inspiration behind it um I followed my
husband to me and I had always worked in
restaurants and I looked around and duh
trying to decide whether I wanted to
start a restaurants a rough business and
whether I wanted to own my own
restaurant was it was a was a real leap
I had always said that I would never own
a restaurant it's just too hard it's
just too physical it's hard to have a
family life those sorts of things and
but when I came to New Haven i had taken
to about six months off started churning
around and looking around to see what
was available in New Haven he found that
I thought that we could offer a little
bit more so that's why we started in
hand
then a bun for you it sounds like it was
more like from before your time but like
what yeah inspiration for the free
restaurant oh well yeah it's not really
so much my story it's actually my
mother's story which is that she ended
up here in New Haven because she
followed my father whose first job when
he left Cambridge was here at the
Medical School is my dad's a doctor my
mom always wanted to do business and
business wasn't something that in her
generation was something that women it
went into and was encouraged and my
grandfather who is one of my mom's great
heroes was a fantastic businessman she
always looked up to him so I think not
so much as food for her it was getting
into business that interest her she
happened to like food and she studied
nutrition like a lot of women did back
in those days and then I just kind of
followed along because I wanted to help
my mom out combined with it was a I
always knew that I was an artist so it
was another way of expressing myself
artistically and combined with bad
grades so it's like my destiny being
here with you guys that's really my dad
is going to be proud it's it's really
the closest I'll get to yell the greed
avarice so then for Casey is very young
is very young restaurant so what was the
motivator for you starting so I actually
wanted to no desire to start a
restaurant whatsoever I wanted to open a
cheese shop in New Haven but after
looking for several locations I found
where we are now on the corner Whitney
in trumbull and it just sort of made
sense the cheese is really perishable
it's very expensive it has a very slim
window where it's like a peak ripeness
and what are you going to do with all
this stuff if you're not going to sell
it very quickly so the restaurants are
have evolved out of needing to use the
cheese and so that's what we cup of
there you go um bun you mentioned a
little bit of a academic difficulty
there what kind of educational
background to each of you think I'm
influenced like in any way if it if it
did influence on like your restaurant or
like like where how how you run your
restaurant mmhmm yeah yeah I've had
plenty of academic difficulty but I do
come from like a really solid academic
background being like my parents both a
higher degrees you know my dad's got a
couple PhDs and I'm d they both went to
you know world-class school so I grew up
in that kind of environment anyway and
then I all I went to private schools
where the classes were really small so
no matter what I was always kind of
pushed the study but later on on that
base I think I've just kind of grown
into someone who's really curious about
everything that there is to possibly
learn I think I get that from my
educational background but also for my
parents who are immigrants you know and
I think something about immigrants to
come here often if you're not coming
here because of economic reasons you're
coming here because you're an explorer
at heart and ultimately that's what I am
and I think my education has kind of
made it my destiny to do what I do in
the way that I do it Ernest Donald IE
what do you think how do you think any
kind of educational background
improvements aside from working my way
through college and worked in
restaurants
pay for college so it's more life
experience the life experience
absolutely and how's cases been
influenced by it um like I have a
master's degree in gastronomy and sort
of a an anthropological look at food and
I think that that's part of what i want
to do with caseous is to have people
come in and have me teach them something
about what they're eating I think that
that like herbs are assault enhances the
flavor of the food when you know a
little bit of a better about a little
bit of the background of where these
different sort of artisanal products are
coming from so I think that's definitely
enhanced it together um and then it
sounds like Donna you had a lot of
experience coming in for each of you how
is like how is how much cooking
experience if you had that's coming to
influence your restaurant like how much
actual couldn't experience do each of
you have I don't have any professional
cooking experience we should my business
partner is the chef program and my
business my background is more business
oriented in front of the house and she
does the cooking
yeah personally didn't go to culinary
school I mean I wish I had the time to
do that but I kind of fell into the
business and and didn't get to do it but
I'm fortunate because both my parents
are really really into food my dad's
from Hong Kong and that's a culture that
goes and eats out all the time and he's
just food crazy to this day and then my
mother is obviously pretty food crazy
too and that's why she started the
restaurant as well so with that
background it definitely made it easier
for me to appreciate food and once I
wanted to get into cooking it wasn't
hard to appreciate the craft or the art
or the science of it a lot of life
experience I've worked in restaurants
all my life you know my family is really
into food as well so that that was that
was great my my mother's side of the
paper used to have a small little
Italian deli I'm worcestershire so we
were always there making sausages
selling cheese you know and then I
worked in a lot of cheese shops before
coming back to New Haven very nice um
honored to business tactics I guess the
big question which saw answered but like
it sounds like all of you were John's
new haven for different reasons but why
New Haven why was this why did this
become such a prime spot for each of you
that has obviously given me such great
results autostart do you um well knit
Haven is sort of unique in Connecticut I
mean it has its you're able to live here
you're able to it's a walkable City
within reach of New York pretty easily
it has a drill diverse population as
Yale as sort of an inner city life as
well i think it probably comes as close
to cosmopolitan as Connecticut can get
so if you're going to be in Connecticut
that's insane maybe I think one of the
reasons why I Love New Haven is that
it's small but it's actually worldly at
the same time so you know you cannot if
you want access to like a Pulitzer Prize
winner you've got it right here and it's
in a small town if you want a
world-class scientist with a Nobel Prize
to talk to you can do it right here in
this town you need to talk to someone in
the movie business you can do it right
here in this town if you're in New York
City it's all spread out but me is I
kind of feel like you know and i'm sure
you guys feel the same way about your
restaurants you kind of feel like your
your your cultural lightning rod because
you get all these different types of
people who are coming in and not only
you know award-winning people like that
but you go down Grand Avenue and you've
got the Puerto Rican neighborhoods you
got Freddie fixer parade where it's all
you know black you know you got all this
cool stuff going on and one of the
things that's really important to me in
my cuisine is to make sure that the food
the ethical the healthy the world class
creations that we do at me as is totally
accessible to everybody you know so of
you know a of every race you know of
every cultural background of every
economic background and you can do that
and offer that in New Haven and get
appreciated for because the world up New
Haven is so diverse hmm how about you
blog I'm from New Haven I was born and
raised here and lived in fairhaven most
of my life and I just you know I was
living up in Boston
working at a world-class cheese shop and
I saw a lot of less similarities to
Cambridge where I was working and New
Haven and thought it would you know I
wouldn't fit the business model that was
trying to trying to do but mostly just
because my family's here coming back to
home gotta come back down very nice um
so what is the most successful method of
marketing that you use like between
versions of advertising like
word-of-mouth anything like what has
been the biggest pusher for your
business well these days it's it's
Facebook and Twitter I mean they are
they are the big business drivers we
just had a contest on facebook make your
own pizza contest it's actually still in
the works and we were surprised by the
5,000 votes that we received I mean it
was it was incredible even to us but
that is a huge huge huge driver these
days I think print ads have probably
gone the way of newspapers and magazines
so waste of money word of mouth is
really the only successful marketing and
Twitter and Facebook are basically
amplifiers of word of mouth
yeah yeah yeah I think we all believe in
the same stuff then I use all the
techniques that she actually does but
ultimately I think all that stuff can
gently comes from the fact that the
restaurant business not it does take
tons of time and it could be exhausting
at times too and you're not think it's
super rich from doing a small restaurant
at the same time but i think what
separates businesses who do well is that
the kind of marketing you do you don't
even really think of it as marketing you
know you're talking the hours don't feel
long because you're having these
wonderful relationships like earnestly
and from the bottom of your heart with
the people that you work with and the
people that come in you know I don't I
don't have like a like a division
between like this is my business fragile
this is work and this is life or
whatever you know I just can't see
everything in my life everything
everyone is my family and I think that's
what ultimately our marketing comes from
yeah that's agree with both of those and
then for us my decision at the very
beginning we opened caseous was to
really never spend any money on
marketing whatsoever but to never say no
when asked for a donation so I mean but
you know we always have we have some
sort of minimum donation we give a gift
certificate out for like a cheese board
and two glasses a house wine and we must
give out you know five a week to
different people that come through and
then we do a lot of big events
throughout the year but I know these
guys do as well that definitely generate
a lot of PR and even just things like
this it's awesome it's connecting with
you guys um what kind of relationships
do you like personally up their guests
like do you make efforts to go out into
the restaurant and I'm speak with guests
who are coming through
have like just to kind of interactions
like what just yet what kind of
relationships if any are there in the
restaurant yes to all those things that
you just said yes well absolutely I mean
that is that's probably the most
important thing that you do in the
restaurant if you're sitting in an
office and paying bills or doing
anything else and you're not really and
you have customers in the restaurant and
you're probably not doing what you need
to be doing making connections with your
guests finding out who they are it's
it's almost like basic market research
to how did you like that dish you know
are we are we performing up to
expectation who are you what kind of
custom are you coming through our doors
all that stuff is is anecdotal you a
student or you a visitor did you come
from the lacrosse team that just had a
big tournament last weekend did you come
from DC did you come so yeah all of all
of that is all important anecdotal
information for us and helps us form a
relationship with them and hopefully
give them what they what they come to
our restaurant floor
yeah i agree with done um yeah i guess
like the approach that I take is that
it's not necessarily approach if I were
a dog I think it'd be a lab you know I
just love people you know I'll follow
anyone home pretty much you know I just
I just do not like that favorite right
then I think it I think it helps to have
that kind of nature though you know just
like people a lot and also I don't ever
really want to feel like I'm actually
working or when when I'm at me is why I
was kind of the philosophy that far to
die tomorrow you know not to be morbid
or anything but you know am I having
really awesome relationships with people
and you know that's ultimately what I
want to achieve at me as I I I want to
literally have meaningful relationships
so to give you an idea you know if I I
got a lot of best friends I know a lot
of people but i'm working on a whole
bunch of projects right now working on a
film project and i'm working on it with
an anthropologist who was an undergrad
at Yale ten years ago you know and now
he's done a master it and a doctor and
we're still buddies also working hina a
book right now with a buddy of mine who
was a graduate of Yale whose opal
excavator of mine as well to you know so
just as examples I mean it and it goes
on and on just so many productive
relationships have come out of
friendships that were originally formed
that Mia's actually any waiter that you
see at me as has started off as a
customer first because they they
appreciate the cold trip me is when
people actually leave me as to move on
they always refer somebody else because
they don't want just anybody to come in
and take their spot you know when it's
not about the money you know it's it's
it's about how people really emotionally
and with their heart feel about well
what it is to be a part of of our family
no 4pcs yeah I you know being in the
dining room during service is huge I'd
like to try to think and have all of our
our employees try to think of it more as
their home and so invite someone to your
home don't think of as a restaurant you
know where what you want say what you
want it creates an atmosphere when
everyone's just happy we deliberately
have high stools in the upstairs dining
room so that people can interact
one-on-one with the with the servers so
they're not like being looked down on
are looking up at them that was really
important I think it creates an equality
that's really nice you know that whole
going back to explaining the food to
people that creates a dynamic it kind of
breaks down those barriers and we do we
do a lot of special events like on
mondays and tuesday evenings we have
special dinners and you know cheese
classes and that that breaks down the
bear even more so we really get to
become friends with the people who are
coming in and we're feeding just really
important you shouldn't dislike people
that are feeding you you know it's the
one thing that you should definitely the
one service like hate your mechanic
maybe your doctor but definitely not the
people feeding it you should definitely
love them and then kind of just like as
a closure for business tactics how much
money does one need to start a
restaurant like and how do you get that
money together so I know for each be
it's been a different situation but like
how did startup work
um smorgon second mortgage on house sell
everything you have they beg the bank
tell them you're different than the
other five restaurants that they've
funded and failed I mean it's hard it's
really hard and particularly today I can
imagine must be impossible I mean even
lines of credit or impossible these days
but don't ever underestimate how much it
takes to get it going you really do need
to get yourself through the first year
it's not just getting the doors open
it depends on what kind of restaurant
you want to start how much money whether
you're willing to bootstrap it do the
work yourself I mean they're all up
there a hundred other models to with
investors and backers and points and but
we didn't use any of those we just in
our particular circumstance we just
started our restaurant and then we
started a second restaurant kitchens inc
behind it using the proceeds from the
first restaurant so we did it be
probably not the smartest way yeah I
know my mother actually got the money
borrowed borrowed from her family and
maybe even friends you know so I'm sure
we owe money all around town still but
for myself it's it's a constant
investment you know restaurants are
incredibly big cost consuming so either
I put more money in my pocket or I put
it back into something I love so I
generally don't try to maximize you know
how much I'm making because I want to
work on all these projects that me is
this really really busy allows me to
hire all sorts of different people to
work on all sorts of tangential projects
that are part of me is that I could
never probably do any other job you know
because I've got so much flexibility
with how I spend my money but
yeah yeah I knew a guy no no it's a it's
uh you know combination of going and
talking every bank New Haven has a small
business association they're useless now
there are there are there are lots of
resources out there but without equity
you're not going to get anything and I
had a computer to my name when I started
caseous that's that was my equity so
some family supports some friends you
know just going around and begging
people I did learn that restaurants are
not the most volatile business though
it's actually women's boutique fashion
did you miss one season and that's it
you're stuck um but but really it is a
lot more money than you think it's going
to be to get things going we did a lot
of the work ourselves anyone that's been
to caseous knows the tables are a little
shaky I built them I'm not a carpenter
you know we have a lot of things that
are just kind of very homemade but i
think that's that's important too so it
depends on what your business model is
if you want to go ultra chic you're
gonna need a lot more money I couldn't
believe how much even just one glass was
or the kitchen equipment alone it's just
it's daunting so all right so now it's
like kind of the basic of the restaurant
um how do you determine the price of a
meal or an item Emil
the price of a meal well technically
it's three times ingredients cost items
and Emil meaning items in a particular
dish how many items yeah ticular dish
that's determined by combinations of
flavors generally I mean you would sort
of a blow-up a range of flavors that you
want to complement each other and you
can try to compose the dish based on
those
I think that's all I can say about that
yeah all right I will I like to comment
that real quick though because i think
it's again really situational for each
particular restaurant you know if you
come to caseous and well i'll use wine
for example you might get a glass of
wine from us and it might be like two
dollars cheaper per glass then the same
exact wine at i'll use a restaurant
that's not here but I visa but you need
to look at all the costs associated
because they have two to three people
waiting on you we have one they've got
fancy balloon wine glasses from right
Alan we've got these old kind of
scratched up ones yeah um they've got
tablecloths you know linds are insanely
expensive like just those natural guys
they're good restaurant they're a great
restaurant um in case you and Casey ases
ok no but we have we have maybe four
guys in the kitchen and they've got 10
so you know you are paying like my
friend John owns 116 crown you go in
there it's visually spectacular you're
going to pay some for that experience so
i think it's it's very situational when
you're talking about how you cost out a
dish yeah i mean a lot and a lot of
times for us will have if we have two
specials in the night if i get a
fabulous ingredient that I think is
unreal and I want to use it on a special
and it's a little more expensive and if
I triple the cost which we do as well
and it seems to be a little higher than
I want it to be right then maybe I'll
lower that one but then the other
special will add a little on to it and
so you have lost leaders you know it's
all very very situational as far as what
you know what's going on at what time
what you're using and what your costs
you know doing business are also for me
at say that I've got like a
philosophical and marketing approach
marketing would be a little bit like
McDonald's and that the low end is
extremely low
and but I'm not trying to be like
McDonald's as I should philosophical and
it's the philosophy that I want everyone
to be able to afford the highest quality
food that you can possibly imagine me as
rice literally cost six times more than
anybody else's sushi rice people don't
really know that because we've got
quinoa knit we've got organic O'Groats
and we've got ground flaxseed in it
everywhere else it's just rice sugar and
vinegar that's traditionally white rice
I thought we've got Brown racing at the
same time the average person doesn't
know that but it really supports my
belief that everyone should be able to
have access to pin fantastically healthy
food with the best ingredients you know
we don't carry a farm salmon you know
because it's terrible for the
environment and people complain about it
once in a while well and say oh you got
this cheap stuff this arctic char stuff
arctic char costs twice as much as farm
salmon you know and then when we carried
wild salmon it literally cost five times
six times as much expense yet six times
as much as as the farm meanwhile we've
got roles that are three dollars so if
you do the math we're not making any
money at all using those ingredients but
that's alright because it supports a
philosophy of being able to make great
food accessible to people and at the
same time it's fantastic marketing
because you fill the seats up and you
actually spread goodwill and we don't
have a lovely restaurant like these two
restaurants you know it's me as actually
as is pretty crappy looking you know
there's I'm not spending a lot of money
on infrastructure but we are on on all
the things that you guys r which is
quality food and then so the flip side
of it is that we've got difficult dishes
so you know if you read on the internet
not which I do now and then people like
yeah me a sense it's $45 roll you know
it yeah $45 it doesn't cost me fifteen
dollars
cost me far less than that it's $45
because we got to go out and catch short
grabs ourselves you know and it's
back-breaking work and also it's it's a
piece of art that we're actually giving
by the time we're actually done it takes
a long time for us to produce it
compared to see that three ala troll so
that's what you end up paying for with
something that's 45 bucks sounds like
the highest variable is always labor um
another question how do you hire a chef
like what are the qualities you look for
whatever you're choosing someone to
actually cook your food race right I
just hire agents detailed completely
yeah for the cheese's only four we look
for consistency we look for Ken I can
you know can I mean we have a chef who
is the sort of creative person behind
everything we're hiring other people to
execute that we look for consistency
knife skills those sorts of basic kinds
of things
yeah I I went through many many chefs
over many many years I've got the best
team I've ever had and I've literally
had you know you name the category of
person and I've had it you know and I'm
a bleeding heart so I've given so many
people chances i'm not i'm a better
businessman now so my heart bleeds less
you know I put up with less it's a once
in a while and in the past I've gotten I
don't hear so much anymore but I've
heard stuff like man you got your guys
are all Mexican you know these Mexican
guys do a great job you know they work
hard and you know and they're they're
not expensive or whatever and I'm like
well a I'm not hiring them because
they're Mexican that's nothing to do
with it we've had everyone else you can
possibly imagine not work out prior to
them and then be there there are no
cheap people you know you can't have
sustainable sushi like we do and not be
trying to be sustainable in every
possible way so our guys are definitely
one of the some of the best paid people
on the line that exists I'm positive
about that but I I demand a lot from
them and their Mexican because when I
hired my first Mexican chef I originally
hired him as a busboy he walked in i'll
never forget it with his cousin sitting
speak any English and I just fired
somebody and and we were bang and busy
and then his cousins were like oh what
one can when can he start and I was like
well if you can tell him to start like
right now that'd be great and they're
like right now I'm like yeah it's town
right now and so they tell him he looked
shocked then I was like well listen also
tell him that this thing works out but
he works hard if he likes it this may
change his life I'll tell you what
happened he's got two cousins working
for him now because every time I wanted
to hire another chef I taught him sushi
eventually stay went from being a bus
person
sushi chef and then every time we got
busier and I need another chef cousin
yeah I was like hey you want me to hire
somebody or you know look for someone at
a culinary school or do you want to give
someone an opportunity and now he's like
the patriarch of his house his whole
household as economically changed any
commands tremendous amounts of respect
and it's interesting nowadays like with
all the media attention that we get and
it's funny because there's this a
wonderful girl who is a great friends
with a waiter of mine who's actually
graduating this year and her boyfriend
family owns Bolivia's number one
culinary magazine so they're coming down
to do a spot on us so we're going to be
huge in Bolivia but uh so but I asked
you know when when they take my picture
I think they can take me on the line so
that they can get all the other guys
down in the photo as well so they can be
part of the spanish-speaking magazine
because their families and they will
appreciate it so I know what I'm talking
about
we've been open two and a half years and
I have I'm on my third chef he's been
with us since we opened and pretty much
everyone else in the kitchen is either
friends of mine or his and he and I have
been friends 12 13 years now I think
that what we look for in people who work
in the kitchen is tolerance because I'm
a micromanager but also they have to be
a little crazy our guys work they
usually come in around nine o'clock and
they usually leave like around midnight
so endurance certainly that's their
choice I've offered split shifts they
don't want them and you know some of
them have families but they really love
to be there and they love what they're
doing micromanager but I want lots of
freedom so they we all meet every monday
we planned the entire week together you
know someone who doesn't want to do that
doesn't want to be part of that planning
process someone who doesn't want a some
freedom someone who just wants to come
in punch a card stand there punch out
that's the kind of person that we we
weed out real quick like within hours so
we have going through some people right
now everyone that's in there is a tight
family and they're all somehow connected
but different ways so I think that's
what I really look for in the kitchen on
the subject of staff how do you hire
wait staff and what kind of training do
they go through
we hire win stuff based on their empathy
I think how much they can immediately
empathize an interview with with
whoever's interviewing them how gives us
a clue as to how they can empathize with
the guests wait staffs jobs difficult
because they have to almost immediately
sighs someone up and try to figure out
who they need to be for that person
meaning are they in a business meeting
and do they really not want me to be
here and they just want me to be really
efficient or my part of the show tonight
so they have to have the skills to
immediately sighs their customers up and
that's what we look for the rest of it
we figure we can train we look for a
little bit of skills restaurant skills
our nice retail skills are okay but
empathy is the big thing we hire for are
you a nice person or you do enjoy what
you're doing do you do you get a kick
out of being hospitable welcoming
helping people leading them guiding them
through the menu explaining different
menu items it's not it's not always an
easy job so they have to get something
out of it we try to find out what that
is
hmm yeah i agree with you a hundred
percent i think we all kind of look for
the same things like you can't teach
care you know that's something that's
really important but i don't personally
higher too many of my chefs or I'll hire
anyone actually these days anymore the
employees just got to hire each other
because they know the kind of culture
that they want and they know what I
stand for and live for I think allowing
that to happen has really been the best
thing like that I don't sit around and
just interview people and that i
actually just trust the rest of the team
to have the judgment to bring in the
right people and weed out the wrong ones
pretty quickly I'm not done yeah and no
yeah but I would say just a handful
years ago I was just you know I was a
half the people I was letting in just
kind of sucked so and now that I don't
do it on my own I think it just it's
it's way better you know we get a higher
padding average two things cute and
single okay good kyleigh kidding I'm so
many guys like that too no they I our
big thing is that they have to be extra
verts you know I want people to talk to
the customers so if you're very shy
quiets not gonna not going to work out
most likely but we're at the point now
where most of our most of our wait staff
is is brought in by our veteran wait
staff I haven't really hired in one
myself in a while I fire them though
and then what do you as owners actually
do it a day-to-day basis well the
beginning of the week is taken up for me
with what payroll bill-paying sort of
accounting work monday is kind of a drag
deck you come in you look at what you
did over the weekend you try to get your
act together do your payroll get
yourself set up for the week and then we
have regularly scheduled staff meetings
I try to work with we have a couple of
we have a new manager that I've been
working pretty closely with on the floor
at night and during the day we do a lot
of Yale business so we have a lot of
phone calls to answer a lot of special
events to book and pretty much as it
gets to the end of the week saturday is
sort of an easy day because it's a day
you come in and you're just on the floor
that's it you just you don't have to
worry about the office you don't have to
worry about answering the phones to book
parties you're just there you're able to
enjoy the night as it unfolds take
reservations make the book that's pretty
much what I do in a day to day basis
yeah I do a lot of that sort of stuff I
don't do any I don't do any County stuff
for bookkeeping stuff so I just can't
stand it you know like I literally am
not really all that interested in
counting the money or or any of that
stuff truth I just I just know that
we're busy and that we're paying our
bills so I'm pretty psyched about that I
try to make it into the restaurant you
know we're only open five days a week so
it's not all that hard to do we're
closed on Sunday and Monday so it's not
that crazy of lifestyle when people say
that your hours are really long will my
actual hours at the restaurant all that
long I just go in for the rushes and
stuff because I love seeing people and
our love people but most of my time is
actually spent doing creative stuff and
learning as much as possible I pretty
much live in a library some I'm doing
research all the time losing sleep over
my new new menu that I'm actually trying
to roll out kind of having a battle with
and then I'm constantly working on other
projects at the same time too and these
days I won't do like you know cooking
lessons generally speaking i'm going to
do catering there's just so much stuff
that I just won't do for money because
my time is so important to me so when i
do do cool things it's like working with
kids like i was just at the Y you know
showing a 100 kids how to make sushi you
know but I wouldn't do the same for like
kids went to my prep school or my middle
school where its private you know where
their parents could afford it so I'm
just kind of doing stuff that's cause
related and then that's perpetuating
into good business you know that yeah
yeah hi I'm at the restaurant a lot I
like to get there before anyone else
just because it's quiet and I think
there's a little do not disturb button
on the phone and turn that off and then
I can kind of answer emails and you know
it usually starts like around eight
o'clock and then people start rolling in
around nine so then then just you just
get pulled in every direction and then
customers start coming in phone ringing
in you know there's always something
going on I try to try to be the last one
out the door on most days now my brother
works with me so I've given him some
responsibilities like the schedule but I
still have to pour over it because I'm
not able to relinquish anything just yet
but in our third year we're going to get
a on site sort of like Bill keeper type
person but I made the agreement with my
accountant that I would do all of it for
the first three years so you're like
eight more months to go and then I don't
have to touch and that financial stuff
again and I cannot wait because I hate
being in front of computer I often will
go in the kitchen and cook for a little
bit just to destress I love being in
there but then I love being out talking
to customers too so it's just it's all
over like people sometimes ask if they
can shadow me and often i'll just say no
because I don't really know what I'm
gonna be doing and most of its
inappropriate anyway so it's just you
know it's okay you're all over the place
we need lynZ we ran out linen so you're
gonna shoot to west haven or you know
ice you know I I'm The busboy I'm the
errand runner phone answer you just do
everything so on the subject of the menu
on how often do you each change your
venues like is it purely seasonal are
there other motivators that go along
with it like different cultural
celebrations or anything like what makes
you make a change
our menu changes are kind of changes too
often our menu changes according to the
whim of our chef Denise a pad and it's
generally because we've had some product
move in or out of the market that we
can't get or the we're looking at
asparagus that came into the market
early and we decide we want to use it we
want to use a particular item this
friday we're changing three small plates
and three main plates sometimes it's
minor changes sometimes it's made major
changes but there's no real rhythm to
our menu changes there they're seasonal
but that it doesn't go every four months
it doesn't wear every three months it
can you'll see you might see a dish on
there this week that you won't see next
week either because it's time to come
off because that particular item is not
available before we have a couple of
staples on our menu we have a chicken
dish that we just can't take off and
probably our tuna is the most popular on
the menu right now and that's uh that's
also a staple that the fried spinach
yeah the fried spam okay imma smoked up
nachos which I can't get rid of either
but but everything else is is subject to
change yak and 2009 maybe maybe 2008 I
was changing my menu you know evolving
it every two weeks it's a lot of work
yeah it was just crazy and then 2009 I
was doing at mean every three weeks and
then and I always carried pads with me
and I always think about it you know i
pad next to bed and just new ideas
coming all the time and november of 2009
my computer broke down i couldn't access
my menu anymore and it was the best
thing that's ever happened because i
left it a home for months and months and
months and so it's really been the same
pretty much since for the last bunch of
months and but right now i'm actually
trying to roll out i'm always trying to
roll out my Mona Lisa you know and I'm
never really satisfied with it but right
now I'm trying to get rid of chicken on
the menu you know I've got a couple
items I got rid of beef altogether
because I don't believe in industrial
beef and I don't really believe in
eating mammals in my heart anymore I
think ethically the vegetarian diet is
is the best diet for humanity and the
planet anyway so I'm going to get rid of
trying to create replace my chicken
dishes with the emulated soy chicken
thing and kind of going up the
vegetarian alley on that and I'm also
talking with different people on using
invasive species like the lion poisonous
lionfish because
it's running rampant all over all over
the oceans and no one's using it as a
food source so I've got a few
organizations that want me to create
something for them and for them to
publicize it and there's also a skate
explosion in like the Carolinas because
the top predator the shark has been
overfished and I'm trying to work that
but trying to work the logistics of how
to get the fish to me and how Ford it
bolts going to be and realistic it's
going to be to do that sort of stuff
with those are just kind of tip of the
iceberg of what the new menu is going to
be about cool I disagree with everything
you said meet me now my I was a
vegetarian till I was 12 my parents are
hippies so I have to rebel but we we do
we do source all of our meat from very
good places our chicken as a heritage
breed our beef is grass-fed most of our
pork is local from right here in
Connecticut so um so there no no I'm
gonna come that burger or sound palette
sure yeah yeah but we uh we we change
our menu seasonally with the the four
seasons we're in our spring menu right
now wednesday through saturday or open
for dinner we do two specials at least
every night those have a theme
wednesdays raw thursdays wild mushrooms
friday is a pacific halibut can't have
Atlantic Carolee have any fish that I
found that's really sustainable if it
comes out of the ocean if it's farm
raising its bad too and then Saturday we
do veal and it's it's free range it
walks around but then we kill it but
every day we also have a different tart
we always have a different braids
vegetable every day we have a different
tarian soup every day we make a
different butter for a bread-and-butter
board every day so it's everything is
constantly changing and everything's
made fresh we don't have very much
refrigerated storage because most of
it's taken up by cheese so we get
deliveries every day of pretty much all
of our products which is nice it's kind
of logistical II a pain but it means
that we don't have to hold a big
inventory which is great it costs a
little more in some cases but in other
cases there's a lot less waste but I
think changing stuff constantly has been
something that's really helped us out
and having our menu always sort of
changing because we have have a lot of
customers that come every day and you
know the regulars there's there's one
Yale professor that literally comes
every day on mondays and tuesdays after
he eats lunch he has us make him
something to take away for dinner he's
still alive he's gotten fatter look
alive um so I you know I would just get
I would get bored I get bored by the
time you know the three months rolls
around at the end of a season I you know
I'm so sick of seeing peas underneath
the chicken or in the mac and cheese I'm
like yeah he's great at the beginning
like peas and then you're like peas are
stupid so it's always really exciting
for us when we get to launch our new
menu and you like to get lots of
feedback which is also great we
typically will launch a seasonal menu
and then for the next two weeks it'll be
tweaked and changed and we'll ask you
know customers of course this one
professor you know about what they like
or don't like and they'll they're quite
frank and so we can say okay cool this
will that's that's something we can do
it some we can change and that's fun you
know just who wants to do the same thing
every day that's just boring I wouldn't
know what to eat after a while there's
only so many things our menu
so what is your most popular dish
reassurance for us i think it's the
chicken or the nachos wanted nachos I
have no idea to text truth whenever I
know that's how about a businessman I
have no idea I yeah I would say it's
probably about 20 dishes or our dishes
on dishes what you guys do so like
probably 20 different roles that are or
a little mini dishes that are really
really popular I make what stands out
with surprisingly popular me as is the
vegetarian sushi that we do and about
the vegetarian sushi by the way is the
reason why we can actually do fish that
is break even or or we even lose money
on it depending on what it's going to
cost that that that week because
vegetarians kind of so much less and and
we've got the largest vegetarian sushi
menu in the world so we're drawing all
these people we're actually coming in I
could guy have no idea we have a I think
it was a year into opening we stopped
doing handwritten tickets just because
it was getting way too confusing and
another server side good handwriting and
we my brother came on he's kind of
techie so we got this fancy touchscreen
put it all in and he tracks how many of
each dish we sell and I had no idea how
it works so well I could look it up and
get back to you guys but I don't know
it's weird you know on on any given
night you'll you'll come in and if
you're the second seating will run out
of like six things certain nights one
thing will sell really well others
something else if I had to venture a
guess I'd say the macaroni and cheese or
the grilled cheese sandwich people like
the cheese
how do you choose your suppliers for
your foods like what like our other
obviously blood between sustainability
and just even like the types like the
types of providers that you have just
like what are the main things that will
stand out that make you choose them what
their business practices are they have
to sort of fall in line with what our
business practices are whether they you
have a sense or you know by reputation
that they treat their people well and
fairly where they get their product from
whether whether they're what they're
saying is true you have a sense of what
they're saying is true where did I get
their food from and then delivery
schedules how many times a week they can
deliver to New Haven a lot of our
suppliers are out of New York I know you
Syd Wehner right out of Boston I see
them in front of your restaurant every
day and their front of ours too so you
have to have a supplier that's
dependable when you're out of something
are they going to be able to get it to
you are they downtown every every day
it's a balance of those price too I mean
price shop a lot once you find a
supplier you probably go with them for a
couple of months and then shop price
just to make sure you're getting the
fairest price but but sometimes the
fair's prices and always always the
price you're paying
could be could suffer customer service
wise too so it's a lot of just keeping
an eye on those things balancing them
out yeah we just we just dropped the
biggest sushi fish supplier in the world
and it's been really really challenging
for us because we can't get the same
kind of fish that we used to get but and
the reason why we dropped them was
because i went to the Boston seafood
show and for months and months for
actually over a year my sales person was
like you know what got a sustainability
expert and and New Jersey you know and
he's got to do this and that and i went
to the Boston seafood show which is the
biggest seafood shown in the Western
Hemisphere and I went there with Time
Magazine's environmentally or the year
who came to the restaurant and and hung
out with me and went down and met all
these people in Greenpeace World
Wildlife etc etc and then I went to the
booth for our distributor and her I met
the sustainability expert and he didn't
know anything about sustainability and
they had a big bluefin in their sushi
case and I I just got the vibe that all
they want to do is just grow as a
business and just pick them bigger than
they are and it's just like you know
what I'm not I'm not even gonna work
with these guys anymore and I'll tell
you my food even got better because
putting myself in a really difficult
situation made me become much more
creative as a chef again I create all
these new dishes with all these new
types of fish but that I don't that
sushi the cuisine of sushi wouldn't
usually use as fish so basically I'm
just using that as a sample just going
to support what we're talking about
yeah we use a lot of specialty we use a
lot of different suppliers a lot of them
are specialty like these thing you know
Sid Wayner their astronomically
expensive but the service is there I can
probably get the exact same product from
them that I can get from one of the
bigger distributors and it's going to
cost me more and I know it but it's
going to come in in good shape and we
just don't have the space or the time to
deal with if something comes in and
isn't up to par this is the best time of
year though because we have about five
different farmers that we buy direct
from that some we have to go pick up and
some will deliver to us but it's
starting to roll out now slowly you know
some green leaf lettuce some little
things here and there but in another
like month and a half we just we drop
most of the big purveyors and go all
local and the price is better and the
quality is better and there's that story
attached to it which is huge because we
make sure that we're really good friends
with all these people who grow for us
and then as far as meat goes we pretty
much buy all of our meat from this
company called d'Artagnan and they they
don't use any hormones and antibiotics
on either meet and then if they'll go
farther if you ask them and make sure to
have grass fed and as local as possible
you do have to double check the fish has
been the hardest to to stay on on point
with I've switched purveyors several
times you know everyone's trying to
sneak little things by you we had a bag
of muscles come in this was a while back
and it said Pei Prince Edward Island
main now prince edward island is in
canada so i was very confused to the
label so i called the purveyor up and i
asked them I say mean so well it's kind
of off the coast closer to Maine
than it is Canada but it still Prince
Edward Island because we're close to the
island and it was it was just [ __ ]
for lack of a better word and there's a
lot of that in food so you got oh you
got to watch out for the smoke and
mirrors especially in higher end food
organic sustainable these are marketing
terms now I think in California alone
there are 54 entities that can certify
something organic so so where's the
regulation what does that mean it just
it's very confusing so we're constantly
trying to keep an eye on our purveyors
and watch them and that's why you know
the more local we go the better because
we can physically go to the farm and
pick something out of the ground and
take it back to the restaurant and
that's when you really don't have to do
anything to it put some heat and some
salt and some butter on it it's done um
when you guys are putting earlier dishes
everything often you suggest wise or
that has other kinds of Drake's to do
with them how do you suggest a wine like
how do you pair a wider is whether drink
with the dish and what kind of thought
goes into that matchmaking well pairing
wines with food is so subjective these
days I mean you know some people like
buttery wine with a buttery dish I might
prefer an acidic line with a buttery
dish
we've had a couple of beer and cheese
tastings that have surprised me Jason
I'm sure you've had the same thing
alright yeah BR / one every time yeah
yeah it's really interesting but we just
we just try to prevent the present' of
varied wine list we have probably 125
bottles on our list so hopefully our our
service staff is is well versed in what
we have our list and they can determine
what the guests preferences lean toward
and suggest appropriate one we leave
that up to the up to the server we train
the server in the server then leads the
guests in the right direction we hope
not me is is not really focused on one
actually kind of threw it right out the
window I've got to house wines and then
I let people just bring their own lines
it and pair it up themselves and stuff
and then we've got all sorts of
different sockets that I create there
but I don't really try to pair anything
up the sake is each stand out in the
same way that some some of my better
dishes stand out and can stand alone we
have about I think about around 50
bottles I had a pretty clear-cut plan
with the line and beer we have more beer
than wine we don't have any alcohol
liquor just because size-wise we're just
too small no enough room for any of it
but the I like to pair beers with a lot
of our dishes our servers have certain
go two beers that they can suggest for
certain dishes we do like to talk about
that a lot our servers probably don't
know the one as good as they should and
a lot of that is my fault because I
switch our list up bi-weekly I mean just
I will find something I like and I'll
bring it in I'll throw on the shelf and
I'll you know hey guys you know the
pre-service meeting this is brand-new
give a taste okay good if you like it
cool if you don't don't recommend it we
don't have a very diverse selection of
one it's all wines that I kind of like
and we have a lot of customers come in
and they want something very specific
like a like a buttery Chardonnay or
something I have nothing that will
satisfy them so I like to recommend
something else that's nowhere near what
they would even think of tasting and
maybe they like it and it's introduced
into something new and maybe they don't
and they're kind of complain but I just
don't have the space and I also when it
comes to getting drunk I like very
specific things so kind of pain in the
neck with that the food will you know if
you have a special request
we will gladly try to do our best to
make it your way but but but with the
wine and beer I kind of like what I like
and I don't like people drinking things
that might overpower the food or the
cheese and so that's that's really an
important thing but as far as pairing
goes tell people you know if it's good
food and good wine and you like it
that's right and if you don't then it's
wrong it sounds like each of you go to
varying extents with proper control you
have over the menu but um like in your
own words how much control do you have
versus the chef and what food is
prepared where food is offered really um
we have a kind of team approach at our
place Denise does a lot of research our
chef Denise she does a lot of research
she does a lot of thinking about
imagining pairings and what a dish might
take tastes like a lot of times we'll
have a chance to make it taste it
everyone away in on it can kind of be
tweaked this way can it be tweaked that
way we have us jason said earlier some
dishes that that stay on the menu for a
week and we decide for a variety of
reasons that they're not exactly
conceptually they were much better than
they are on the plate and we pull them
off immediately we've had dishes that we
have not had a chance to try and Denise
will say oh we have a menu change it'll
go up in the window for staff because we
always brief our staff and they get to
taste it new things that come on the
menu and one of us me or something to
look at it and will taste it we will
just pull off the menu immediately
sometimes it ever even makes it to the
menu so we have a real arm team approach
to that
sometimes Denise will have created
something in her mind that even she that
she's not happy with by the time it gets
to the plate and then that comes off the
memory
so we like to talk about it we all have
very strong opinions about dishes and
what what we think our customers want
yeah I often find myself making a phone
call to the restaurant and talking to a
chef and being like a this is the idea I
have these are the thoughts and and this
is why I created it and then I'll come
in a couple days later and be like I'll
have you guys experiment with that then
they'll show me something that works or
that doesn't work you know and I like
yourself I get opinions from everybody
and ultimately when I've created a dish
I kind of let evolve in everyone else's
hands because I'm not on the line and
often the way they tweak it makes it
much better than what I've actually done
in originally imagining it and also it
gives the chef's a sense of empowerment
too because there's so many chefs out
there which is just a different
management approach that you do exactly
the way the plate is exactly supposed to
look the way that that originally
structured it for me my philosophy is
that I'm working with a lot of people in
collaboration with other people and the
only reason why I don't have a dish by
one of my other chefs is because no one
has actually created a dish that can
that's actually on the level that it
should actually make the man but I'm
excited to see something that a chef
would one day create and put on our menu
yeah like I mentioned before we we have
a kitchen meeting every monday and plan
out the whole week worth of specials but
then every day depending on what comes
in and what conditions in things change
our food isn't super complicated we like
to just highlight ingredients over
techniques I'll often have an idea give
it to the guys in the kitchen see what
they come up with you know everyone has
a little bit of a input in it I have got
two rules no squiggles no foam
that's just not our style that's all
it's not it's just not something I want
to see on the plate you know we try to
limit the other kind of loose rule is a
sort of a limit to how many ingredients
are going to go into a dish you know
keep it around five if you have to get
up to seven okay but but make it make
the dish about a particular ingredient
and highlighting that ingredient not you
and then finally what would each of you
order if you were eating at your
restaurant like you have a particular
favorite dish you're a particular just
any kind of like real favoritism towards
something the change is like minds of
chipotle pork shoulder right now it's
really good spicy yeah I eat at me as uh
you know for time four or five times a
week and I always eat like a humongous
salad or two because it's one of the
best things I think that we do
especially as you're talking about in
the season that we're moving into you
know we got three different farms
including the Yale farm that supplies us
with all these different incredible
vegetables I love our miso soup and then
I'll always have a few pieces of sashimi
fish I just really keep it simple I
definitely not stay away from like you
know the potato skin fused with arctic
char bone top with havarti cheese with
Asian shore crap I don't I don't go
crazy you know I I eat really really
simply and which is just a reflection of
how I eat at home too so same i like i
like to go into the kitchen and see if
there's any fries in the bowl that's my
number one thing I mean you know
if somebody messes up than undercooked
or overcooked a hamburger um I'm right
there I'm ready to go burnt grilled
cheese they know to call me down to the
kitchen I will eat the mercurial cheese
and in a heartbeat and then beats I'm a
beat fanatic we always have beats on our
menu in some form so I eat beets every
day so always just just go grab pic i
don't i don't think i've sat down and
had a meal at caseus ever but i like to
go into the kitchen and and see what's
you know what's been burnt or that
french fry bowl man Dan they're good
yeah that's that's that's my I dream
about them then finally just uh any
questions from the audience hi my name
is Matt and I've had the opportunity no
the privilege to fancy all of your
establishments but my question is how
did you come up with the names of each
of your establishments minds latin for
cheese and i was really criticize when
we first opened because everyone was
like no one else has to say it no one
knows what it means and so therefore
you're going to confuse people and it
was sort of along the business line you
know the whole idea is it's a
conversation starter no one knows how to
say it I mean most people call us kazoos
so we get to have the opportunity to
tell them how we say it and not correct
them but just say oh we call it Casey's
and then we get to explain to them what
it is and therefore right off the bat
right in the name or teaching people
something so that's that's kind of cool
I think
mine was a name by my mother after my
little sister shortly after she was born
that's when the restaurant opened up and
but now that I'm in power next year
you'll see the name it'll be fun but it
won't be fun it'll be buns then I'm
gonna steal the under Rawls logo so
it'll just be an ass with my name above
it zinc is a traditional Bistro material
when we first saw the empty storefront
was long and narrow they just put on a
mahogany and glass new glass storefront
and it reminded us of a traditional
French bistro and the guy who owns the
building is called George so drew and he
had put Z door handles on the restaurant
so it seems like a no-brainer anyone
else questions
alright well I guess that's it thank you
guys very very much for coming and
answering our questions it was a
pleasure to have you all thank you there
you go